every truly dedicated gamer knows that
Comfort is key then you saw them get
graviton forces out the beats and now
you don't have the sustainability
and that is a keyboard some players go
to incredible lengths to get things just
right but if you're searching for the
true Comfort freaks the biggest weirdos
of them all look no further than
professional CS go so we have avanek
that is playing with Weavers sound which
means that left is right and right is
left so basically what he is on the on
the left you watching the right you know
from cursed postures to carpal tunnel
inducing Mouse grips CS GoPros have
found some rather Creative Solutions on
their quest for the perfect way to play
it's just it's really awkward to look at
his feet are like propped up so he's
almost like horizontal Lounge in his
life if you're not allowed you're not
trying players will do whatever it takes
to ensure that they are performing at
their Peak and there's really no right
or wrong way to go about it unless
you're this guy these are my controls
I don't know what it's called but this
one I jump with the question mark I'm
the top is right left
and I play inverted Mouse as well I just
shoot some natural meet Dion fasher
Dirksen the hard style obsessed Dutchman
whose keybinds are a complete and utter
bastardization of the norm however
despite his hideous controls he's very
very talented and has come to represent
one of Cs Go's most prestigious Orcs as
well it's all done to fascia yeah he got
at the door but whoa fascia it's his
moment to step to the plate it's his
moment to be the hero doesn't realize
the players drop down no nose he knows
the audio cue giving up he's chasing
this normally can't get away and it's
just only one and a wounded Rook see it
back this is a one V4
Eva's clutch Refresher
is looking for the shot he's got it as
well so how the hell did faster get to a
major while playing CS go like it was a
flight Sim Why did no one stop him and
is it possible that his config could
actually be the better option maybe it
opens the eyes from some people as well
because there's a lot of people asking
for convicts from Pro players you know
but like just make your own it's gonna
be okay just feel what you're
comfortable with those like conflicts
ain't nothing you know if you can see me
playing with this then I can make it to
fnatic then why can't you playing with
the I don't know backspace I I I don't
know like everything is miserable yeah
hey guys so before we dive into the
video I just want to say with the
holidays coming up I gotta let you know
that we at the score Esports do have a
line of merch and we have a new line of
colors coming out for our touch grass
hoodie it's really cool it's comfortable
high quality be sure to check it out
okay so on paper faster seems like your
typical Dutch lad he enjoys attending
EDM festivals watching F1 and eating
whatever the hell this is but before he
embarked on these hollandic Rites of
Passage and even before he was uploading
Cod trick shots to his YouTube channel
fasher was just a kid learning about
video games from his dad you see fasher
wasn't born with the inexplicable drive
to use non-standard keybinds it was
actually the product of nurture not
nature fasher's baffling habit actually
came from his dad's love of flight
simulators who taught you how to do this
stuff
you are right
I learned it by watching you it's pretty
standard for flight controls and video
games to be inverted since that matches
the natural motion of using an actual
flight yoke but faster learned to play
literally every game like that except it
wasn't by choice his father set every
game to his bizarre flight sim inspired
inputs and faster was just too young to
know how to change the keybinds himself
yeah basically he rebounded every game
he was playing so yeah but I was just
sitting on his lap playing a little bit
of Day of Defeat or sometimes like
Wolfenstein
return to the castle I think it was
called
uh yeah that's a type of games he was
usually playing and then yeah I could
play for 10 minutes on his lap let's say
that and then obviously he tells me oh
this is jumping oh this is backwards uh
this is moving and then the afforded
Mouse just yeah but you don't know any
better you just learn it you know so
whether it was Day of Defeat or
Battlefield Vietnam fasher was forced to
carry the burden of his father's custom
controls and he basically never heard
the end of it every time that faster
played games with his friends they were
understandably in disbelief but to fash
her it was never an issue
after all it was all he knew literally
everything just always gets carried over
to a new game like first I always when
like even now when you start new games
it's just wait wait I need to change key
findings now I understand it's
completely random if you don't know
about it it's like for me it's just it's
the same as using wasd if you know what
I mean for most of faster's Life gaming
was something he did casually it was
something to do with friends or past the
time between studies but one day when
faster was already ancient by Esports
standards I.E in his 20s he watched a
professional CS go match that changed
his life forever that was like in that
period of time where you don't really
know what you want to do do you want to
start school again do you want to go
work do you go there then I um I saw the
IEM
now ESL one cologne major final 2014.
was actually fanatic against nip they
were playing the third map Inferno and
creams was playing there and I thought
holy [__] this is insane so I bought
Counter-Strike listen people get into
Esports in all sorts of different ways
but
franchise has been around for so long
that it's kind of weird to think of
someone faster's age getting into the
game after watching competitive CS go
but since nothing with faster is
ordinary after witnessing two Swedish
Titans battle it out he decided to pick
up the game and give it a try but of
course first things first fashion needed
to switch over to his soon to be
Infamous keybinds now I mentioned the
inverted Mouse thing but trust me it
gets so much worse fashion moves
backwards with semicolon left and right
with comma and period crouches with M
and jumps with question mark and that's
not all fasher moves forward with right
click only
what is that
what the [__] is that now if you're a
MOBA player clicking to move may seem
natural but let me explain why that is
far from normal in the world of FPS in
any first person shooter the mouse is
almost entirely reserved for aiming
adding a secondary element especially
when it's crucial as movement feels way
too chaotic and remember faster's Mouse
is inverted meaning Up Is Down and Down
is up now obviously like any keybind
this is something one could get used to
but the idea of having to flick in the
opposite direction just makes me shudder
despite his ungodly controls though
faster got really good really fast so
much so that in 2016 just two years
after getting into the game he got
signed to his first org over the next
few years fasher hopped between several
different European rosters trying to
make a name for him
it was only faster on the side oh my God
I say only flash here with three kills
make that four and the fifth only
fashion only fashion it was only faster
on the side yeah
very good player at all faster how's he
done that two with the USB you might be
able to get a third with the Scout and
he does all of a sudden this round is
turned on his head but faster eventually
hit a wall he toiled away in tier 2 and
3cs for years without much success and
it wasn't like he was getting any
younger sure he was determined to win
and was the star of almost every team he
played for and yet big teams just
weren't noticing it so what was the
problem well obviously I can't say for
sure and while faster was incredibly
talented and had a really good work
ethic Europe is quite literally
counter-strike's most competitive region
it's hard to get noticed without a
little luck that said you can't help but
wonder whether in some ways he was sort
of playing the game on hard mode default
controls are meant to provide the most
comfortable and efficient way to play
for the average person and sure some
people might make slight tweaks that
Inspire eyebrow raises here and there
myself included but when a player's
preferred controls are this different
from the norm they might actually be
hindering their performance how far
could faster truly take himself while
playing the game wrong well as it turns
out
all the way
that can be so nature it's making his
way out of long as the first there's the
refract from faster osues double faster
oh my goodness gracious faster what a
one tap that was I thought that he goes
both deals there for a second a few
continued faster with the AIDS forces
opted for a match 10 he knows that the
head Kevlar could have been an issue it
isn't for ecstatic they find a first
faster dancing back and forth in the
back of the side as he finds himself a
second five seven drawn oh my good God
faster the Dutch Delight for faster it's
an ace in the last of the second half
5v3 40 seconds time is there but faster
Wow's getting a nice shot a secondary on
rig on hold up jumping jacks ain't gonna
work here and blink they're losing
players left and right along another
Squad faster finds one more and faster
just Aces it faster's time on ecstatic
proved that he was A Cut Above the Rest
and eventually his hard work paid off in
August of 2022 fasher signed with the
same team that inspired him to pick up
the game in the first place fanatic but
why exactly would he top-tier org want
to sign a player who'd never really
competed at their level before was it
just morbid curiosity about his
grotesque keybinds or was he actually
that good well it turns out that on top
of having absolutely cracked aim faster
was known for being an aggro freak hell
he played so crazy that he was even
accused of cheating which as we all know
is the Hallmark of every free noteworthy
up-and-comer homie wasn't even a w
Warrior he was a
Mouse to mercenary and that's gonna open
the hell was that Foster just comes in
and kills two players and popped on with
the addition of faster fnatic finally
had the spark they've been looking for
and he eventually helped bring them to a
top eight finish at the Rio major
with already no one was ready double
entry for fascia oh wow yeah he can't
even see it because of the scope
aggressive plays coming up from the
phonetic side reasserting some control
wide swing from Bashar and he'll take
every single remaining kill quad on him
this might be the beginning of the end
flash has found the blind spot walks in
the fire walks above them and locks ends
out of it fnatic played in the Elisa
Masters where fasher put on an
incredible performance to help lead his
team to Victory loses the fight now they
can hold down the defuse because faster
has not got an angle tap up one look for
the second and glaive gives up the fight
bashes backstab though SMG bursting
through Roy is going to go down and he's
taking that backstabbing relatively soon
Basha engaging against one and two
looking for the faster as Messi gets one
and faster mans with a triple it was
also around this time the faster started
popping up on more people's Radars not
just because of his sick highlights but
because his Dirty Little Secret started
becoming public knowledge thanks to a
picture of Travis Scott a tweet from
zipple and a viral video made by a
certain Esports media Outlet fasher
became the Talk of the Town and as happy
as he was about his Newfound popularity
fasher quickly learned that Fame comes
with a price nah I'm completely fine
well when people ask me in real life I'm
always fine to put the putting up a
small conversation but now nowadays when
they react on my YouTube or whatever I
can't be asked to reply to it anymore
I've said it so many times so people
should just find out theirselves there's
probably if you Google fashion key but I
think there's going to be stories why I
play with that fasher has found success
in a pretty unlikely way you gotta admit
the way the guy plays is insane but
somehow it works
really really well it's kind of a dream
you know like playing tier one Cs and
I'm obviously I couldn't have uh wished
for anything better than now reaching
the qualifiers of the major and like if
you told me half a year ago I would be
in the corner Finance of the major would
win a like a tier one tournament and
like I wouldn't have to leave you you
know
fancing with controls more wasd was
popularized by Quake Legend Dennis
thresh Fong way back in the 90s and sure
it's a familiar and comfortable way of
playing but are we limiting ourselves by
conforming to the status quo everyone is
different and something that works for
one player may not work for another so
why is it that the majority of people
stick to the defaults maybe just maybe
the only thing keeping you from
greatness is a few custom keybinds so
tough task ahead for Team Liquid to stay
alive at the pro league playoffs faster
with two quick headshots that's a lesion
the eckendor and OC all fall no chance
no trades and no pissed around for
liquid it's fanatic to take a
one-nothing lead
I'm really not in the habit of uh
clicking on links that are captioned hot
dog thingy that's uh what the [__] is
this
is it like some oh God all right I'll
keep the image open